hi everyone it's joanna here today's
workout is an indoor
walking workout to get your steps in and
also to boost your metabolism
so we want to increase your heart rate
and burn
lots of calories there will be a focus
on your core
and we want to work on your waistline so
let's start walking
let's start by warming up our body so
let's start by marching on the spotter
case
so this workout is going to be low
impact there will not be any jumping
involved but
we can also take it a notch up okay
depending on your fitness level
so let's start marching on the spot and
i want you to just
swing your shoulders front and back and
just really
release the tension on your upper body
and
drive your knees higher okay
good job so keep marching relax your
shoulders do not tense your shoulders up
and just relax all right now what i want
to do is just
take a step in and out okay arm combo
forward and up forward
and up that's it so we're also going to
warm up on
our upper body and throughout the
exercises
i want you to really
focus on your core and be conscious of
working
on your core as well okay keep going
side step up and
forward good job now let's get into some
heel digs okay
so heel digs stretching your cuffs out
tap forward left and right and tap
forward
good job left and right good keep a
slight bend
in your knees throughout the workout
remember that
there should always be a slight bend in
your knees to avoid
any injuries so do not lock your knees
okay
stay low and keep a slight bend good
now reverse leg curls okay
so kick your heels back to
your butt and just open up
your chest and squeeze your back
muscles good job keep going
and reach okay wide step
good and remember remember i always say
this
pace your breathing breathe in
and out all right the better you are at
pacing your breathing
the longer you will be able to sustain
your workout
good and now just march it out
and give me few crisscross okay so right
leg back
left leg back crisscross this is going
to be
the last warm-up and we will start
the workout okay good job criss-cross
slight bend in your elbows and step
and cross good
one more and just
shake it out okay so this workout is
going to combine
cardio total body cardio as well with a
core focus all right
so the first workout is going to be a
step back and
a twist all right step back and twist
step back and a twist that's
it good so left leg back twist
rotate working on your obliques
twist and step good job
and twist so as you twist i want you to
drive your hips back forward
feel the engagement on your core and
pull it back
step and reach and whisk
there you go okay so stand tall
chest up good
step and twist step and twist
alternating between your legs
that's one more and twist
good job okay next is going to be a high
knee skip
so imagining that you're skipping but
without the jump
and what i want to do is bring your knee
up knee up
knee up and up okay there is a slight
bounce
but it's not a jump okay so tiptoe
tiptoe tiptoe and what i'm going to do
is try to drive
your knee as high as possible and feel
the crunch
on your abs okay there you go
imagining as though you're skipping but
without
the hop so just tiptoe tiptoe
good job find your rhythm find your
rhythm
up up up and up good there you go
keep going stay light on your feet
stay on your toes
and just breathe breathe
that's one more and good okay
now let's work on our obliques okay it's
going to be a standing
side crunch with a pull down so start
tall
step wide what i need to do is crunch to
the side remember to the side so
knees pointing out and to the side
it's not forward okay it's out to the
side out
to the side point your toes
and your knees out and try to drive
your knee to your elbow okay
good job and go if this is too tough
you can start low and eventually
bring it higher up
good everybody needs a starting point
so start where you're able and
slowly progress okay pull it down
drop it down remember it's your knee
reaching your elbow all right and
every 15 seconds you get a short break
and just remember
to march it out next is going to be
scissor jacks okay
just like jumping jacks but it's low
impact so
what i'm going to do is drive your leg
back
with your arms just like a jumping
jack again no jumping but i want you to
stay
light on your feet good
left leg and right leg back arms up keep
a slight bend in your elbow
come on drive the arms up really use the
strength
from your core and your upper body and
drive it back down
pull it back down don't just let it fall
down good do that squeeze do the work
on your shoulders as well this is a
total body workout
okay you can work on your core
by doing standing ab exercises as well
it's not all about crunches keep going
and good all right okay now
let's start on the left let's go double
side step
twist double side step and twist
again remember staying light on your
feet
and twist okay drive your elbow
towards your knee knee up and twist
cross crunch good stay light find your
balance
do not collapse okay stay tall
chest up good arms just by your sides
stay light and double side
step and cross crunch good
and breathe you shoot your you should be
a hundred pumping
i know i am good job
you are strong come on let's sweat it
out
let's burn calories let's boost our
metabolism
okay all right very very well done okay
now it's going to be a white low step
with a cross
so what i want to do is point your knees
out with your toes out
it's sort of like a white squat but what
you can do is to support
your arms on your legs okay so wide
and back wide and back so use your arms
to support your thighs and help
push yourself up okay as you stand tall
squeeze your core
and twist twist good there you go
crunch and twist stand tall
and push this is a
really good inner side workout as well
use your upper body to help push
yourself back
up good job guys you are
halfway through this one
round okay good job push it up stand
tall
push it up down and up okay
a short slight recovery but we want to
still be working
on our car this is going to be a side to
side reach okay
it might look simple but the focus here
is to really engage your call
and drive yourself back into the center
and back into the center so it's not
always okay
it's not penguin left drive
pull it back and get your call pull
yourself back
pull small movement but really suck the
belly in
in one straight line okay do not
collapse down
one straight line side to side
reach as you're reaching for someone
oh pull it come keep reaching pull it
back
pull good keep reaching and pull
good job one straight line
i know you're feeling the burn on your
shoulders as well
keep going pull pull
and pull okay good job all right
okay now let's work on our left side to
begin with it's going to be a side tap
with an uncombo it's going to be reach
and pull
okay so again keeping your knees soft
reach and pull
working on the total body as well as
your core okay
reach and pull 20 seconds
on each side and we want
to change to the other side
okay change over reach and pull it back
down
good
[Music]
squeeze feel the squeeze on your
waistline
working the waistline pull it pull good
remember to stand tall as you pull up
okay
good few more reach and pull
that's two more and good
shake it out all right same thing
working on our left side to begin with
now i'm going to step forward and pull
okay
so this will really hit the mid
and the lower call core all right so
again keep your knees slightly bent
reach forward and pull if you want to
challenge yourself
reach higher up go reach up
pull good
20 seconds on each side it's going to go
by
really quick let's keep going
a few more and now change side
left leg reach up pull
and tap
and breathe okay reach up as high as you
can
raise your core
look straight ahead last few more
just march it out okay now
take a step back okay the next workout
is going to be a double step forward and
a double step back
okay so throughout this exercise i want
you to stay low stay low
double quick step forward double quick
step back
that's it quick step forward quick step
back alright so remember
keep yourself light on your feet
you don't want your neighbors to be
yelling at you
so stay light double step forward double
step back
okay now let's lead with your left leg
left leg forward
left leg back and back
good keep going you should feel the burn
on your legs
your thighs keep going
small step forward small step back
that's one more and just
shake it off okay oh
right let's go two more exercises
the next is going to be a simple heel
tap
okay again the goal is to drive
your heels up do not lean forward okay
let's go heel tap and add a slight
rotation good rotation with
heel taps tap and tap
good tip toe you are doing great
10 minutes into the workout
strong legs strong body strong core
crunch it up breathe out
within and out tap tap do not stop right
now
come on up and up nice
last five more seconds tap
and tap push it and
shake it out okay one
final workout and you will get a shot
one minute break okay
skaters so what i'm going to do is step
back
cross over and really try to bring your
body down
and reach the floor okay i want you to
challenge yourself
try to tap the floor and really
drive your body down but still keeping
your back flat
and not hunching forward if you're doing
this this is wrong
this is just lazy all right engage your
core tight core
look straight ahead back flat take a
white step to the side
and tap cross over as wide as you can
final workout and you will get a
short break so stay with me tap reach
go lower nice cross over
tap one more
[Music]
and slowly come back up okay
take a short one minute break
and you know this we want to repeat the
entire
circuit once more you are halfway
through
your workout stay with me stay strong
and keep yourself hydrated
[Music]
one round down another round to go okay
so this round i want you to really step
it up and challenge
yourself you can do the easier version
but i will also show you
a more advanced version okay so if you
want to challenge yourself
do follow along all right are we ready
the first workout is going to be a step
back with a twist
all right so stand in a neutral position
start with your left leg
let's go step back twist back
step and twist okay good twist
working on your obliques rotate and pull
it back
starting nice and easy
just a small step back and
rotate good
there you go guys only 12 minutes left
stay with me okay i want you to finish
this workout strong and sweaty
good keep going step back pull it
and pull stand tall good
rotate as far as you can and up
all right good job okay next is going to
be a high
knee skip okay so just like skipping
bring your knee up
bring your knee up bring your knee up
that's it okay
and now the challenge is to bring your
knees higher up
or get into escape
okay choose your option if you want to
you can just bounce slightly
get into a skip balance on one leg and
the other side
all right so choose your option if this
is too much for you
then just up up up up
if not let's go bounce good job
so there will always be options for
beginners
or for those of you who want to
challenge yourself a little bit more
but it's all right we progress okay
as you repeat this workout you might
want to try
this advanced version go up skip
skip and skip a few more
and check it out okay standing
side crunch remember step wide toes
pointed out
arms up crunch to your
side okay remember knees and toes
pointed out arms to
the side if you want to challenge
yourself again you can add
a slight bounce just to drive
your knees a little higher up
if this is too much take it a notch down
and just stay
and back okay choose your option
let's go those of you who feel like i
have more energy
and then let's keep it up with me
up up good just a slight bounce
not too high just a slight
bounce a few more
and check it out okay caesar jacks all
right
so same thing arms up take a step back
and just seize your legs
all right remember really drive your
arms up
and down control your arms lead your
arms
do not let your arms lead you okay
if you want to take it a notch up you
know this seizures
get into a scissors okay
this is a full caesar jacks
and remember look straight ahead pace
your breathing it's just like a small
shuffle
pace everything stay with me
breathe last 10 seconds
let's get our steps in
few more one two three
okay march it out all right okay
now a little bit of coordination start
on your left okay double step
crunch double step cross crunch
are we ready all right stay low
keep it right double step cross crunch
double step cross crunch
cross and up
cross good job remember bring your
knee up not your elbows down
i want you to maintain a tall position
knee up good
keep going
twist double step
stay light
arms out good
[Music]
working also on your hip mobility
okay all right wide
low step with a cross okay so step wide
with your toes
pointed out remember you can use your
arms to support you
so just like a white squat down cross to
the back
down and cross to the back okay so stay
low cross
down and up good push away
push and point cross
and point good job push cross
and point take this time to recover
cross and point cross and point
who wants the advanced version
yeah let's do this okay down crisscross
down crisscross okay
this is the advanced version down
crisscross
down and cross give me two more alright
stay with me one more down and
crisscross
okay good job all right you are halfway
there
a short active recovery but still
working on our core
arms out side to side reach
all right okay let's reach like you mean
it
let's go pull it pull as far as you can
working on the waistline pull
pull good keep going
keeping your legs straight step wide
pull and reach
keep going guys pull and reach
chest up look straight ahead and go
tighten your abs go good
can you feel the stretch along your
waist
pull pull and reach good i feel the burn
in my shoulders as well rich
rich and rich
who's still with me okay let me know in
the comments below if you're still with
me if you are still going strong
okay now sidestep with an
overhead reach okay so stand in a
neutral position
let's start on our left side up and
reach good small step
to the side and reach keeping your right
knee
bent all the time okay
20 seconds on one side and
we will change to the other side a few
more
one two three and now switch over
pull it
good feel that squeeze in your back
muscles as well reach up and pull
pull you are also working on
your lats squeeze squeeze
and squeeze okay
i am absolutely drenched in sweat i
always am
in all my workout videos because i do
this workout
life with you okay so whatever you're
feeling right now
i can feel it as well okay now let's
take a step back
and reach forward okay challenge
yourself
remember reach your arms higher up
feel the work on your shoulders feel the
stretch
on your back muscles 20 seconds on each
side
it's short so give me a good
quality round keep going
that's one more and switch good
keep pulling up reach
and pull reach and pull good job
find your own rhythm stick to that
rhythm
let's speed it up last five seconds
three two one and good job
oh if you're still with me
now let's take two steps back okay
this is going to be a low step forward
and back okay double step forward stay
low
leading with your right leg step back
all right
it's not a complicated exercise but it's
a very effective
workout for your legs step back
stay low a slight bend and step back
feel the burn on your glutes your quads
and your hamstrings as well okay
now leading with your left okay forward
back step forward
and back step forward
good
shot break good there you go
last one more forward back
and just oh breathe guys
two more exercises to go okay heel tabs
all right let's do this let's really
drive your heels up okay
tap tap tap and tap
all right remember step
wide find your balance find your rhythm
and keep going
if you want to challenge yourself let's
go bounce
a slight bounce remember to
not lock your knees okay
slight bend and a small bounce and a
slight
rotation to your left and to your right
[Music]
you got this
that's one more and
final workout my favorite
skaters okay so the challenge here is to
really
reach for the floor start in the middle
cross your left leg over okay cross your
left leg
tap the floor go as far as you can
and tap
really reach and tap
remember to always keep your back flat
chest up do not hunch forward just so
you can reach the floor if this is too
much
then just tap on your knees to begin
with okay
are we ready for the final 20 seconds if
you want
come with me hop if not
just stay and keep going with the
regular
skaters find your balance and get your
car
last five seconds last burst
let's go and oh my gosh
my heart rate is going crazy it is at
177
bpm and i'm at 2.5
kilometers okay oh well done
almost three kilometers breathe in
breathe out
and take this time to just release okay
shoulder rolls
bring your heart rate back down
remember that your cooldown is as
important
as your workout so don't
skip this last three minutes okay
roll and now just
reach for the wall grab your legs and
just
stretch out your quads
breathe
and now place your left leg in front
keeping it straight
just reach forward slightly okay i want
you to feel the stretch
along your hamstring good just reach
forward
if you want to you can try to reach the
floor if not
just rest your hands on the opposite
knee
good job and now change
the other leg stretch it out
well done guys that was intense
such simple movements but when you
really put all your energy and effort
into it you will really feel the burn
and you will really have a good workout
session okay
oh and now just reach my heart rate
is too high just stretch your hamstrings
and now just give me three deep breaths
in okay
so ready breathe in bend your knees
reach up stretch up
and breathe out again breathe in
reach up
one more for good luck let's start with
stay strong
breathe in stretch
and out okay guys
very very very well done let me know in
the comments below
how you got on what's your heart rate
like how many steps did you manage to
get in
and if you are sweaty like me okay
do this workout at least two to three
times weekly and combine it with my
total body strength
training exercises for best results
alright
and don't forget to check out other meal
plans and also workout plans on my
youtube channel and also a lot more
fitness tips
to guide you through your fitness
journey and
i will see you next time all the best